hello everybody and welcome to part 15
of let's play penumbra overture once
again I'm very sorry but I figured out
the answer while you weren't here but I
will show you it as I could not before
oh yeah oh yeah I still know this can't
be me waiting one more jump oh yeah
ah no aha okay oh right II and then
technically I can go forward there and
then right here and then there okay
what happened was I was so concerned
with smashing things that I completely
forgot that I could use things as in
with my hand so when I went up here I
had my hammer out or my pickaxe
and I didn't have my hand which is right
there and if I'd had just done this I
would have seen it
oh I'm stupid you all probably knew that
and we're laughing at me but that's okay
I don't mind that's why I'm here all
right where am i oh that's a problem
yeah here oh all right
butter we got oh mine yeah I will get
out cuz I believe in myself
Oh cart ride Cartwright Cartwright oh
yeah
oh no oh whoa well [ __ ] that yeah your
chains listen up my cart ride
uh-huh alright fine fine no cart ride
today what we got bring it on oh I see
okay all right so I do how to get the
cart going somehow but how do I do that
uh-huh Oh Billy
I bet it's Billy oh and also something
else that was brought to my attention I
have a glow stick and I should use it
more cuz I'm a dumbass Oh what am i
doing what am I doing with my life
I don't even know I don't even know Oh
ha ha ha Oh more rocks I love this love
this get push ramming speed they load it
up and more rocks all right here we go
here we go
Oh aah come on love it
all bolt cutters I'm so stupid oh why am
I so stupid all right come on all right
just go just go take your one Rock
that's not even in there that makes
sense yeah yeah yeah oh yeah aah
soli Oh ed we all wore special
uh-huh uh-huh hell yeah men rise and
turn and vital in his hand whatever I
got some vital in my hand
uh wait that sounded wrong never mind
ignore that uh yep okay kitty let's see
what do we got here
uh huh Anna lid yeah I know what that is
you guys don't though right right oh
that's the worm Wow yeah can't wait to
face him again I'm so brave
Oh newspaper what do I do with that let
me read you I want to read you ah
so dumb so uh uh jiggly jiggly don't
make it I don't make a reference to what
I said earlier about something vital in
my head we got wiggle wiggle wiggle
wiggle I got okay Oh get back on now get
you I'm Mona right ah
scalpel I swear to God I will gloat for
second there I thought you were usable
apparently not all right more books more
books okay going off painkillers please
no oh why do you even have this here
what why is this even here if you're not
mine
Oh key in the lock okay so what do I do
about that
hammer it through the other side oh
sauce screwdriver oh yeah
shut up shut up
I'll get away oh oh oh so smart
oh yeah all right that's what that thing
was for get me there we go that's what I
thought oh okay all right
boink dinner you hello who's there ah go
away worm I'm not even close to wanting
come s with you uh-huh yep they look
dead yep
not being able to get town maybe you
feel that way John but I'm gonna get us
out here whether you like it or not my
diet trying or you're gonna die rather
uh oh ye glare bla bla bla bla glow
stick
oh that's much better how do you turn on
and off a glow stick how does that make
sense
uh huh yeah blood and slime everywhere I
want to go through here can I go through
here ah nevermind why did I even come in
here why did I come here
okay all right chair smash be free
creatures ah all right we got uh-huh
yeah it's not that much blood like I've
said before I've seen ten thousand times
more this much blood all right I can't
seem to make it through here so I'm
taking this chair Oh get off the wall
BAM squish okay okay what am I notebook
say why did I even come in this room did
I even get anything nope nope nope
didn't get a thing why come in here Oh
what's this
uh-oh what are these smash all yeah was
that worm their site BAM
oh sorry little buddy ah yeah no oh yeah
finally rock worm ha bah bah sheer
volume of fauna nah bah bah
Rockefeller ah me That's not me who do
you think you are you're not me no one's
me uh-huh ah three adults to larval
infants dead oh no no no no no
yep Babineaux newspaper clippings okay
all right
kill these worm things oh you've no
still growing Farb on their natural
limits adults have now expired gray
three senses natural player prey play
metro play no they have no sense of
smell
ah duh duh lifespan is three days and
Counting that doesn't seem very long oh
come on it's so much reading this is
important I don't know I don't know I
don't know oh okay
why right now good question I've no
answer neither do I uh yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah okay whatever
whatever whatever it's not the only
reason I came in here really really of
all the things I think in here ah
open up Oh open up open up open up get
open yeah that's what I thought
anything no just these slugs and a hole
I can't get in and a light that doesn't
work and larvae that are dead this is a
Dez great great so glad I came in here
oh no not Billy melting about saucy
morsels shut up there are places you
should not go all like here the Reaper
who lives here just like you and I and
just like you and I you must ingest the
living flesh of those less fortunate
oh say it in a less creepy way at a
small place that I do not want you to
visit
oh is it here holiday because it is
darling and in a place that I have been
it's here as an innocent as overwhelmed
by small decaying mine oh no some
buildings no no no no no no no uh-uh
by the way should you turn peckish
alright isn't its finest sauteed with a
little engine oh shut up Billy
oh right ah man oh it was here wasn't it
oh boy wait come here
I don't know I don't know I don't know I
don't know I don't know there's gonna be
giant worms everywhere Oh victory flash
for some reason I don't know why I don't
know oh there goes my flashlight all
right I got a posit here ah ah no buzz
pause all right I'm fine I'm fine
all right I will pause it here but stick
around I will see you in part 16 thanks
so much for watching bye bye